hey guys what's up so I've recently been
watching this show called Revenge which
was suggested to me by a bunch of people
because I thought it was really good I
watched the pilot I was like okay fine
whatever I'll watch the second episode
the second episode took me into the
third and the fourth and the fifth and
before I knew it I was completely
finished with the first freaking season
and on to the next one so me making this
video is kind of stemming from a video
that my sister made on her Channel about
being addicted to TV and how she watches
television and since we're related we
kind of do a lot of things very similar
such as our Xbox avatars unintentionally
look exactly the same in her video she
shows herself watching TV shows wherever
she is doing laundry doing whatever and
I have been doing the same thing this
past weekend with Revenge I don't
usually have a lot of free time so most
of the time I take all of my shows with
me on my iPad so I get to watch them
while I'm traveling but for whatever
reason this specific show I found myself
yelling at characters Amanda Clark she's
oh of course she's back again you guys
just need to kill her yelling at my iPad
I'm like this psycho person sitting
folding laundry yelling at people that
can't even talk back to me no this is
this is insane Victoria I can't believe
it again again with your lies in deceit
I get so into so many different TV shows
and what happens most of the time after
watching the first season they go and
cancel that really makes me angry
because we invest a lot of time we
invest a lot of heart we invest a lot of
love into these characters and what do
they do you string us along you make us
watch this first season and if it
doesn't do so perfectly well what do you
do yeah cancel it you can't keep doing
this to me to us to everyone it's sucked
in and guess what happens left with
nothing but disappointment but sometimes
they try to wrap up those quick end of
the series knowing that they're never
gonna make a season two and just give
you a disappointing ending or even worse
they just cut the show in the middle of
the season and you get no closure no
closure and even some of my favorite
shows when I know they're gonna be
ending like Dexter is ending very very
soon and I'm
I don't know how I'm gonna survive
Breaking Bad is gonna be ending what am
I gonna do probably gonna be perfectly
fine and my sleeves keep getting stuck
in here but I'm probably gonna be
perfectly fine because I'm just gonna
get addicted to another TV show and
completely forget about the other one
Fringe I it was very sad I did cry
actually lost cried I hope Revenge
doesn't end although I don't know how
they're gonna continue on Emily look at
you girl at it again and if you watch
Revenge the one thing that I find so
funny about this show is everybody's
always on the phone always having
someone do her peasant biddings for her
does she ever say thank you nope does
she ever say goodbye when she hangs up
the phone no that my friends is my rant
on TV shows if any of you guys are as
addicted to some shows as I am I feel
you I feel like we're friends let me
know in the comments below what your
favorite TV shows are or even movies so
I'll see you guys soon make sure you
guys like this video make sure you
subscribe and I'm currently in New York
so if you happen to see me roaming
around the streets of
New York make sure you say hi and I'll
see you guys in my next video bye